well the countdown to a new year and a
new decade is almost over
so many of us are thinking about New
Year's resolutions travel is one of the
top resolutions for 2020 right after
exercising more losing weight and saving
money according to the online
marketplace offers.com mark Elwood is a
contributing editor at Conde Nast
Traveler he is here to help us look at
the big travel trends and locations that
we should be going to including space
your bison is right you want to talk
about space yeah would you would you
take one of the first Virgin Galactic
flight okay so I would not go on a
private shuttle because I've seen you
know the mishaps and explosions some of
the private companies trying to go to
space but I would hitch a ride with NASA
Oh which you could do because I think
what people don't realize is yes we've
heard about space tourism which sounds
amazing and Witch of Branson has made it
very much his world Virgin Galactic they
say they will take passengers in 2020
paying 750 thousand dollars each but
NASA is also saying it will take
passengers to the International Space
Station Jeff Bezos has a program that's
going to trial it Elon Musk there's a
lot of people what are some of the other
trends what are you an air B&B kind of
person never done Airbnb I did it a
couple of times but sometimes it feels a
little not clean enough this decade has
seen his trial back I would say that in
2020 and Beyond we're seeing a new kind
of accomodation called the hotel so it's
a home that feels like a hotel so
effectively companies like domi oh and
vivre let you rent an apartment from
someone but you get all the backend of a
hotel you get concierge service 24/7 you
get maid service you can have the fridge
socks however you want so you're seeing
that that's sort of hybrid of it and
also what about apostille apostille I'm
glad you asked
posh hostels so in other words this is
somewhere that historically it's someone
you would think oh this is a bit of a
flea bagging place to stay when you're
19 yeah these these hotels these hostels
have
beds and they realized families would
love bunk beds if we would up our game
so now these posh hostels with bunk beds
clean rooms private bathrooms you and
your family can stay that the generator
in Miami life house that kind of thing
what about Rwanda I saw that was also a
top place to travel when I think of
Rwanda I still think of the genocide
there's been a lot of developments and
new parks and I I was on assignment to
niranda in January and I think you're
absolutely right
we immediately remember Rwanda of the
90s the strategy to rebuild the country
has been really long and very careful
and they've brought tourism in as a
pillar yeah and essentially there's
going to be a new flight from JFK to
Kigali the capital a direct Wow should
be starting this year and Rwanda is a
bucket-list place you are going to spend
quite a lot of money when you're there
because they want it to be a sustainable
process they are saying come see the
gorillas can see the chimpanzees but we
want your grandchildren to see them too
so we're gonna charge you $1,500 for
that experience and it will support
conservation that's amazing I really
want to see the gorillas in Rwanda Oh
magical okay great we'll talk later
so thinking about sustainability as your
medication we all do like Greta tun Berg
and try not to fly okay here is the way
I would approach that I think Gretchen
Berg has raised some really interesting
questions about sustainability travel at
the moment most estimates say it
contributes about 2% of carbon emissions
so it isn't this enormous problem
compared to some other industries but we
should all make efforts I would
encourage everyone if you are flying
think about single-use plastics airlines
and flight use an awful lot of those
throwaway cups and that's a big problem
cruise ships and flights are trying not
to do that Norwegian has said from
tomorrow there'll be no single-use
plastics on the cruises I always say to
people buy a water bottle take that with
you and you travel and that is a little
gesture if you feel you if you know if
your mom lives in California you're
gonna have to fly take a water bottle
let's go thing is there is there a trend
that we saw in 2019 that you don't think
will continue in 2020 that's
question I think we are I think some of
the some of the Home Sharing stuff where
it feels like we're only gonna stay
Airbnb it felt like a baby had killed
the hotel I think we're learning oh no
it means that there's all these new
options so don't worry the hotels aren't
going away stay open-minded Ryan are
exactly P New Year mark Elmwood thank
you so much
you